I'm in Iceland along with a load of
windswept tourists waiting for the
stroker geezer to explode I say geezer
that's the British pronunciation the
American one is geyser and the Icelandic
pronunciation is jeiza which is where we
actually get the name from the original
gays are the first one to take the name
is over there now that one explodes
every day or so stroker meanwhile every
five minutes more or less and here is
something you might not know which is
how it works how a geyser works
somewhere there are incredibly hot props
and next to that there is a water supply
some form of underground river or maybe
just so much heat and so much pressure
that it will force a little bit of that
plug out which will make it much easier
for the rest of follow for the rest of
forward and the stalker geezer will
explode
you